pendant la pandémie de nouvelles formes
de paiement se sont fait remarquer bay
brett klein afp par exemple à quoi ça
sert si notre panier contient plus de
choses que prévu et que notre carte de
crédit nous crie pitié je n'en peux plus
on peut choisir d'étaler notre facture
en quatre paiements sur une période de
six semaines ce qui peut être pratique
pour ceux dont la limite de crédit et
base en plus c'est sans intérêt alors où
est la trappe il n'y en a pas si on sait
se tenir parce que si on nous permet
gentiment de payer notre panier en
plusieurs versements c'est peut-être
pour nous inciter à bien remplir pas
d'attraper donc mais un risque celui de
surconsommer à coûts d'achats impulsifs
d'ailleurs les agences de consommation
canadienne et américaine surveille cette
tendance de près pour voir comment les
consommateurs utilisent ce service
notamment les plus vulnérables
alors un conseil si on considère ces
votes de paiement c'est peut-être parce
qu'on en met trop dans le panier mettons
le côté et donnons nous 24 heures avant
de payer histoire d'y repenser
passés le mot
[Musique]